[Musique]
je n'ai pas mieux la chorale tel chorale
la chorale bol mais voilà qu'au ras
l'bol j'en ai jusque là bas c'est
dommage
en plus en plus j'étais malade et vous
ou un rhume des foins grave et ce à la
campagne dans le métro dans le métro et
à notre dame des champs a prévu un
docteur y est je n'ai que moi mais je
veux dire 'ça y voilà je sais que matin
et soir il aux deux finales mythiques le
roct à le midol lanka change annulé en
piqûre
c'est tout non à 16h10 deux ampoules de
plus qu wable non aux piqûres
c'est tout dans le sens où ces deux
comprimés de mes kilos dur carabinée
dans un verre d'eau laurent piqûre c'est
tout non 3 heures du matin une dose de
facto racing prospère en piqûre dont on
en poule 1 et vous donneriez à pic alors
ils veulent tout en publiant un ancien
champion de tir à l'arc vie ça arrive
mais voilà d'ailleurs j'avais attrapé un
coryza riez vous abbas connais pas cet
agrume d'europe centrale et comment vous
êtes on guérit en soignant une fracture
du crâne
non mais vous avez eu un round fracture
du crâne d'une photo du g des suites de
mon rhume comes carole peut donner une
fracture du crâne en est tellement près
d'un mur
j'ai pas fait le rapprochement moi je
les fais vous aller coller vos petites
vignettes larry tenez regardez tout est
là ses collègues des exodes vignette
fait ma vie est de 70 kelvin 70 voitures
70 bah vous que vous avez pu le deviner
à 2 mètres 70 parce que celle de 71 m'en
sers pas y penser que vous soyez
rembourser sans voix dit j'ai bien
remplie m'a fait du mal a dit avoir pour
être en paix les remplit oui il sait
qu'avec un plume ou non un stylo à bille
passé puis une vie si une boule de
pétanque c'est qu'à un peu gros un peu
la wii est ce vous faites comme
profession ceci organisateurs de galard
par exemple et bien dernièrement j'ai
organisé un gala au musée de l'homme
profiter au profit des petites momie
nécessiteuses à ses finances et parier
tu as parlé ben nouvelle faut un bond à
vous savez comment vous faire rembourser
bah oui je vais à la sécurité sociale
avec ma feuille de maladie ou en
ordonnant aux veaux il vous faudra
l'autre papier papiers d'identité
solange est un jeu mettait la sécurité
sociale pourquoi tant sur mon chemin non
moi qu'est-ce que j'en porte comme
papier peint à bord desquels toute façon
je montre un sous la porte et c'est
alors il va bien de là bas vous entrez à
long terme demande les papiers dont vous
entrez sans papiers alors que j'étais
encore trop fait rembourser parce qu'on
ne monte pas l'entrée est entrée en
bourse à l'intérieur à l'intérieur qui
lui donne ce qu'il veut et le moment de
la personne qui le demandera t qui vous
appellera comme appellera t elle dans
votre numéro qu'on numéro
d'immatriculation du rheu l'appel
qu'elles eurent d'abord en arrivant à
l'entraînement l'intérieur et l humour
jaurès vous aura donné avant voilà bon
alors par exemple vous avez le 219
comment savez-vous quand c'est une
supposition ça vous ennuie rêve est de
120 non pourquoi j'ai horreur
disposition bon alors quand on l'appelle
de 220 hop vous vous lavez et séchez de
gouges m'assois il ne fait pas la forte
tête
j'en ai marre et d'autre alors vous
allez directement vers gaza que vous
appelez banque est lui dit rien vous lui
tendez vos papiers qu'est ce qu'elle en
fait bien pour l'instant il tricote
qu'est-ce qu'elle tricoteront ça dépend
de la saison peuvent vous dire
or qu'est-ce que je fais vous attendez
qu'elle ait fini son rang et quand elle
a fini à l'infini vous tous et à huy
pour qu'elles sachent que si ben laden
évoqué lève la tête
ah bon alors je donne mes papiers et lui
rembourse 20 vous dit vous êtes tombé de
guichet alors je me rassois elle vous
envoie guichet 12 pourquoi ou douze voix
si douce comme j'aurais dit que c'est
une supposition je vous ai dit que
j'avais horreur des suppositions par là
vous allez vous voulez agir ou très
belle aux 13 voilà les est fermé
pourquoi ces fermes et s'il faut tout
prévoir
ah bon alors je me rassois non vous
allez ailleurs les guichets ça manque
pas où voulez-vous aller au 17 0,17 et
larmes rembourse non là on lit comment
vous les préposés liste questionne lit
un livre sur l'organisation de la
sécurité sociale oh là là alors tu
aimeras soit en vous tous et avons alors
élève la tête je lui donne mes papiers
ne remboursant les pas au courant 1
pourquoi n'est pas au courant c'est une
stagiaire
bah oui mais oui la titulaire est
titulaire étant stable alors suivre à
quoi cela vous rencontrez un copain qui
retourne chez lui
je savais qu'il n'a pas quel papier
celui qui vous manque alors que ce
serait moi faites comme lui quand on est
chez vous savez que vous n'avez pas
c'est ça que je reviens un peu plus tard
et voilà et c'est fermé ah non mais
procès permet 16h30 déjà retourna dans
sa tour nord qui se fait moins d'un
autre jour je reviens le lendemain le
lendemain c'est fait
sûrement bon alors je me rasseoir donc
pas dans la rue ça fait ridicule et bout
d'homme alors c'est rare non non je
reviens un jour d'ouverture oui mais
avant vous et à votre docteur s'est déjà
vu vous y retourner pourquoi faire roman
d'un congé de maladie m'a poussé à me
servir ce congé de maladie tu aimeras du
temps au temps pour quoi faire vous
faire rembourser
[Musique]